let's jump to this story this is uh I
don't even I just want to talk about it
it's like not the most important or
political thing but apparently right
before the show we saw this tweet from
um Rick and Morty Adult Swim retweeted
they said Adult Swim has ended its
association with Justin Roiland Rick and
Morty will continue the talented and
dedicated crew are hard at work on
season seven now I know a lot of people
don't care about Rick and Morty or
whatever it's a show you might like it
or not but apparently this is they're
canceling the guy who does the voices of
the two main characters on the show but
keeping the show because he got accused
of domestic abuse is that what it is
yeah domestic abuse and then what's
false imprisonment yeah what tell me
what happened what is the story I don't
know everything exactly but apparently
he had like a domestic abuse a domestic
uh disturbance and then they call it and
then he was uh I think his girlfriend at
the time or girl that was involved in a
situation called the police and he was
like keeping her inside of a bathroom
and then he got charged with both
domestic abuse and he also got charged
with uh let's see like uh I think false
imprisonment